[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public votre
rendez-vous de débats de chronique et de
reportage 90 minutes deux grands thèmes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos Experts le siège de Paris a
commencer les agriculteurs bloquent
l'accès à la capitale sur H autoroutes
au total en France des dizaines de
points de bloc AG sont maintenus autour
des grandes villes quelle sera la
réponse de Gabriel hatal quelle marge de
manœuvre pour le gouvernement alors que
le revenu paysan dépend beaucoup de la
grande distribution ou des règles
décidées à Bruxelles la FNSEA et les
jeunes agriculteurs reçu de nouveau à
matig en ce moment même sont-ils
dépassés par leur base on répond à
toutes ces questions dans une minute et
puis pour notre second thème
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour je vous propose un zoom sur le
temps passé par les enfants devant les
écrans et les effets de ce qu'ils
regardent sur leur
cerveau c'est comme les papillons nuit
ils sont attirés par la lumière et ben
nous on est attiré par la télé par les
écrans tu tu as tu as le réflexe en fait
tu vois une lumière en plus elle va
sauter à tes yeux tu vas le regarder
direct par réflexe
Emmanuel Macron a nommé un groupe
d'expert pour mesurer cette addiction et
ses effets avant de décider
d'éventuelles mesures coercitiv il
vraiment un consensus scientifique sur
ces impacts comment limiter l'usage des
écrans dans débat dans trois qu4 d'heure
mais d'abord des tracteurs sur les
routes et un gouvernement qui cherche à
les renvoyer au champ Samia de chir des
tracteur à perte de vue depuis ce matin
il converge vers la capitale à l'appel
de la FNSEA et des jeunes agriculteur
d'île-de-fance h points de blocquage ont
été montés à une trentaine de kilomètres
de Paris objectif un siège illimité de
la ville Paris c'est la capitale donc y
aller c'est quand même un symbole fort
si on se déplace sur Paris c'est là
qu'on appelle le siège voilà où où il y
a tout le ministère il y a tous les
politiques qui sont là-haut donc c'est
vraiment l'acte final si on doit y aller
c'est là-haut
quoi ce matin une trentaine de tracteurs
emmenés par la Coordination rurale est
également parti d'agent direction le
marché de ringis combien de temps on va
mettre je pense 24 he c'est sûr même
mais bon on a le temps on a le temps de
monter à Paris on espère qu'entretemps
le ministre prendra des décisions des
décisions
nécessaires pour la survie des
agriculteurs à l'arrivé déblindé les
attendes partout sur le territoire 15000
membres des forces de l'ordre ont été
déployés policiers et gendarmes sont
incités à sécuriser les points de
blocage sans forcément
intervenir vendredi le gouvernement a
tenté en vain de calmer la colère avec
une série d'annonces abandon de
l'augmentation de la taxe sur le gazol
non routier 10 mesures immédiates de
simplification administrative des
sanctions lourdes pour les groupes de
l'agroindustrie qui ne respecte pas la
loi égalime ou encore une aide de 50
millions d'euros pour la filière bio
d'autres mesures suivront d'ici 48h a
annoncé ce matin le ministre de
l'Agriculture il y a des sujets
européens cette semaine euh des sujets
européens qui ont été provoqués par le
Président de la République puisqu'il a
souhaité qu'on metre à l'ordre du jour
le sujet agricole je seraiis moi-même en
déplacement à Bruxelles près
préalablement pour parler d'un certain
nombre de sujets je pense au sujet
viticool je pense au sujet d'un certain
nombre de dérogations qui pose question
je pense à la dérogation jachat on est
au travail la prolongation de la
dérogation sur les jacherses fait partie
des mesures attendues par les
agriculteurs pour protéger la
biodiversité la réglementation
européenne leur impose de laisser 4 % de
leur terre au repos
certains syndicats dénoncent aussi une
concurrence déloyale avec l'interdiction
de produits phytosanitaires autorisé
chez certains de nos voisins européens
tous réclament surtout une meilleure
rémunération Gabriel Atal devrait
annoncer une prochaine série de mesures
demain lors de son discours de politique
générale comment sortir de cette crise
agricole quelle marge de manœuvre pour
le gouvernement on en débat tout de
suite avec Pascal Perino bonsoir Pascal
bienvenue vous êtes politologue et
professeur à scienp Paris Nicole Ouvrard
bonsoir et bienvenue êtes la directrice
éditoriale de réussir Agra groupe
d'information pour les agriculteurs vous
êtes également ingénieur agronome
Jean-Christophe buau bonsoir et
bienvenue professeur d'économie à
agroparitetech Université Paris sacclet
et Mathieu croissand bonsoir Mathieu
politique on revoit cette carte des des
points de blocage autour de de de Paris
voilà il y en a huit des grandes
autoroutes hein je vais pas toutes les
citer à 1 à 13 à 6 à 10 à 15 et cetera
et cetera Pascal pirino on est dans un
bras de fer il y a ce symbole le le le
siège de Paris euh réunion prise à
l'Élysée en début d'après-midi les deux
principaux syndicats reçus de nouveau à
Matignon pris catev après le conseil des
ministres qui dit il y aura des mesures
annoncées d dès demain est-ce qu'il y a
un petit peu de panique au sein de
l'exécutif
oui il y a un peu d'agitation parce que
tout de même la crise est d'ampleur et
personne ne s'y attendait une telle
crise euh à dimension nationale avec une
mobilisation un peu tout secteur
intersectoriel avec les différentes
forces syndicales en appui personne ne
s'y attendait et maintenant si vous
voulez les taux se resserrent et se
resserrent bien sûr autour de la
capitale qui est toujours l'objet de
tous les fantasmes le lieu du pouvoir
dans ce vieux pays centralisé qui la
France euh et c'est l'é preuve du feu
aussi pour un tout nouveau Premier
ministre qui euh bien sûr se serait
passé certain volontiers de ce premier
type d'épreuve c'est un premier ministre
il faut pas l'oublier qui est jeune qui
n'a aucune pratique bien sûr des
problèmes du monde agricole et même des
problèmes du monde du monde européen et
que l'on attend au tournant parce que
pour l'instant le succès réel de Gabriel
Atal quand on garde les sondages
d'opinion c'est un succès
d'opinion maintenant il faut en effet
qu'il passe à l'acte et que au nom d'ATA
soit lié non seulement une attitude une
image mais quelques mesures fortes oui
alors c'est peut-être aussi une
opportunité pour lui on y reviendra un
peu plus tard dans dans ce débat
nicoolir on va être dans les clichés
pardon mais Paris c'est le lieu où des
mesures hors sont parfois décid est-ce
qu'il y a aussi de ce de ce symbole là
dans le mouvement c'est aussi le lieu où
on amène énormément de nourriture
aringis pour nourrir est presque un/art
de la population française donc ça aussi
ça compte beaucoup et effectivement
toutes les décisions politiques sont
prises à Paris et à Bruxelles euh donc
s'il y a des lieux où qu'on
doit qu'on doit investir c'est Paris et
Bruxelles ouais et d'ailleurs Bruxelles
puisque on va on va le redire ou le le
détailler c'est aussi un mouvement
européen assez hétérogène d'ailleurs ça
va être ou c'est un lieu aussi de de
manifestation prévu commune des
agriculteurs européens dans les jours à
venir oui oui oui tout à fait il y a
déjà eu la semaine dernière des
premières une première manifestation
notamment de la Coordination Rurale euh
qui qui qui euh qui a commencé à donc
ils étaient encore un peu seuls on va
dire n voilà ils étaient un peu seuls
donc mais si tout se cristallise à
Bruxelles parce que vous avez vu le
nombre de pays où il y a des
manifestations agricoles c'est énorme
l'Allemagne la Pologne euh la les
Pays-Bas la Belgique qui vient de s'y
mettre là il y a l'Espagne l'Italie qui
sont en train de rejoindre le mouvement
ça commence à faire du monde alors
l'image l'une des images symboliques de
cette journée sont évidemment ces ces
tracteurs qui qui convvergent qui font
route vers Paris avec Ben des
agriculteurs qui qui témoignent
justement de ce symbole on on en écoute
un qui vient de looise et qui fait route
vers Paris benah ça fait du bien depuis
le temps qu'on qu'on en a marre en fait
on est content de voir que ça se
mobilise enfin et qu'on va peut-être
être
écouter monter à Paris c'est pas tous
les jours qu'on le fait on l' déjà fait
ça avait servi à rien mais on était pas
assez nombreux et là je pense que pour
le coup là on va peut-être
réussir Jean-Christophe bureau le
mouvement il a commencé par ces ces
panneaux routiers retournés mis à
l'envers ça fait plusieurs mois que que
ça que ça a commencé ça veut dire quoi
vous rejoignez un peu ce que dit Pascal
Perino ça a été on l'a pas vu c'est
passé sous les radars ça a été
sous-estimé ce qui a été sous-estimé
c'est c'est plus général que
l'agriculture je crois que c'est une
vraiment une colère du du milieu
ruralagricole contre bah ce que vous
disiez cet étatisme parisien et qui voit
redescendre énormément de mesures bon
les excès les limitation à 80 km/h étai
les premières peut-être mais beaucoup de
choses extrêmement technocratiques alors
que il ne voit plus du tout les bons
côtés de l'État si vous allez dans chez
moi dans le Loir etcher il y il y a plus
personne ne trouve de médecin il y a
plus d'oftalmau les enfants ne voi plus
à l'école il voit plus le tableau enfin
tout ça les poubelles sont ramassées une
fois tous les 15 jours maintenant il y a
plus de train qui dessert alors qu'il en
avait 10 il y a 20 ans et on ne voit
arriver que des choses qui sont un peu
des enquiquinements et de la taxation ou
là mais c'est c'est assez c'est assez
général au forestiers au un peu tout le
milieu rural quand même qui se sent
extrêmement à part donc ça je pense que
ça c'est tout à fait vrai après la crise
a quand même commencé dans une région en
France assez particulière l'occitan où
la taille moyenne des exploitations est
de l'ordre de 20 hectares alors qu'elle
est de 70 hectares en France et ça ça
change tout parce que les aides sont à
peu près proportionneles aux surface
donc les types ne touchent vraiment pas
grand-chose dans cette région là et en
plus ils sont dans des productions qui
sont vraiment économiquement sinistré
c'est l'élevage viande et le vin en ce
moment euh Pascal périnou il y a il y a
le discours de politique générale de
Gabriel Atal demain est-ce que si on
fait on va faire un petit peu d'histoire
là à ce moment du débat côté politique
et puis peut-être aussi côté côté
agricole est-ce que vous avez souvenir
d'un Premier ministre aussi vite sous
pression non non aussi vite plonger dans
la crise là c'est vrai que là le bain le
bain est immédiat le bain est bouillant
tout de suite le bain est bouillant tout
de suite jusqu'à maintenant d'ailleurs
ce jeune premier ministre tient il n'y a
pas eu de faux pas euh voilà il
s'informe beaucoup apparemment il digère
dossier sur dossier parce que c'est un
élu et un homme politique qui a été
formé dans la métropole parisienne avec
des problématiques extrêmement urbaines
il n'est pas habitué à ce type de de de
problématique
mais on peut lui faire confiance il a du
métier politique et apparemment il avale
dossier sur dossier bien appuyé par son
ministre monsieur Marc fenau de
l'agriculture qui lui a une dimension
beaucoup plus des territoires comme on
dit aujourd'hui et en particulier de ces
territoires de ces territoir mais au
sein de ce gouvernement resserré il y a
quasiment que des ministres franciliens
ça c'est peut-être aussi alors c'est
c'est peut-être anecdotique ou pas
d'ailleurs c'est pas anecdotique parce
que on voit les limites si vous voulez
de la nouvelle politique
h président de la répblque vous savez on
faisait très attention àes équilibres
auelà des équilibres genré on faisait
très attention aux équilibres région par
région aux équilibres métropole urbaine
zone rurale et cetera là la nouvelle
politique macronienne a envoyé bouler
tout ça et on envoie les limites
c'est-à-dire que pour répondre à ces
problématiques où des territoires
entiers semblent rentrer en Jacquerie en
dissidence et bien on a des élus qui ne
sont pas du cru pour gérer ces problèmes
et ça complique le problème je ne dis
pas qu'ils en sont incapables il y a
beaucoup de ministres extrêmement
capables mais voilà cela complique et en
terme d'image vous voyez quand vous avez
un élu qui de la glaise à son soulier à
ses souliers qui va à la rencontre des
agriculteurs j'allais dire en terme
d'image et la politique ce sont aussi
des images surtout aujourd'hui ça joue
un rôle important oui précédent
historique aussi peut-être avec vous
Jean bureau les agriculteurs du Larzac
alors c'est les années décennies des ann
70 mais novembre 78 il y a la première
marche sur Paris je me souviens d'une
photo où les les moutons broutent sous
la sous la Tour Effel dans l'herbe qui
était sous le sous la Tour Effel est-ce
que ça avait porté ses fruits parce que
on entendait là dans le témoignage ça ça
marche pas toujours le le déploiement la
marche sur Paris pour les pour les
agriculteurs le lardac c'était quand
même pas la FNSEA c'est pas bien sûr
bien sû c'est vrai mais bon ça av porté
ses fruits avec l'élection de miteran
qui av
suppriméendéle fr mais il y a eu
beaucoup d'autres manifestations donc
plus plus proche de celle actuelle qui
ont quand même porté leurs fruits he il
y a les agriculteurs disent qu'ils ne
sont pas écoutés mais enfin reprenons
quelques budgets qui tout l'été dernier
augmenté augmenté sous la pression de la
FNSA on est passé il y avait un
programme pour détruire des excédents de
vin parce que le vin est vraiment en
crise là la consommation baisse qui est
passé on devait mettre 40 millions
d'euros puiss 60 on a fini à 217 million
d'euros pour détruire du vin quand même
on peut pas dire qu'on est pas écouté
217 million d'euros c'est 4000 emplois
d'infirmière que les infirmières disent
qu' sont pas écoutés je veux bien mais
que la FNS disent qu'elle n'est pas
écouté c'est un petit peu gonflé quand
mêmeou vous avez parlé de ringis Nico
Ouvrard peut-être qu'on peut détailler
un peu parce que c'est quand même pour
l'instant ringis fonctionne mais tous
les habitants de l'Île-de-France se
posent la question pour les pour les
prochaines 48 he à quel point c'est
vital pour Paris ah c'est c'est vital
pour Paris à quel point est-ce qu' je
sais pas il y a combien d'autonomie quoi
c'est j'aurais pas de mettre la la
panique mais c'est quoi c'est 48 heur 3
jours de d'autonomie cingie c'est fermé
c'est ah je sais pas peut-être c'est 40
% de l'alimentation de l'île-de France
seulement le reste c'est les centrales
d'achat de supermarché mais oui ça doit
pas être pulse de 4ou c'est ça oui
j'aurais dit
oui 4 jours mais oui oui c'est vraiment
très important oua d'où l'importance de
la réponse rapide du gouvernement
matthie on va on va s'intéresser plus en
détail sur cette stratégie euh du
gouvernement face aux agriculteurs oui
parce que c'est une stratégie qui n'a
pas fonctionné en tout cas pour
l'instant la mobilisation des
agriculteurs c'est Durc hein les mots
d'ordr qu'on a entendu ce weekend siège
de Paris pour la FNSEA ou blocus de
ringis côté Coordination Rurale sont
quasiment militaires c'est exactement le
scénario que le gouvernement voulez
éviter c'est comm c'est comme si au fond
rien ne s'était passé comme si on avait
eu un pouvoir très dur qui avait affiché
une fin de N recevoir euh aux
agriculteurs c'est pas du tout ce qui
s'est passé euh dans un premier temps le
pouvoir a choisi de de temporiser alors
pourquoi il a temporisé d'abord parce
que les réponses sont pas simples à
trouver hein faut rappeler que les
revendication étaient extrêmement
disparates que d'un barrage à l'autre
d'un métier à l'autre au sein de
l'agriculture bah il y avait pas
forcément les mêmes les mêmes demandes
et puis en plus certaines demandes ne
peuvent pas être satisfaites d'un d'une
simple mesure ou d'un d'un simple chèque
c'est plus compliqué que ça l'autre
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement a
joué la montre c'est qu'il estimait
qu'il était bon que la colère puisse
exprimer en gros si vous vous pointez
dès le premier jour de la mobilisation
avec des mesures vous risquez fort de
vous les voir renvoyer à la figure et
pour que les agriculteurs rentrent chez
eux il fallait qu'ils le sentiment
d'avoir gagné quelque chose et pour
avoir le sentiment d'avoir gagné quelque
chose il fallait qu'ils aient combattu
voilà c'était tout ce qu'on tout ce
qu'on tout ce qu'on fausfororait tout ce
qu'on disait en au lieu et donc le
gouvernement a joué sur deux pieds des
paroles de compréhension voire de
passion à l'égard de la profession pour
gagner du temps et ne pas jeter de
l'huile sur le feu et de l'autre côté
côté une négociation avec
l'interlocuteur privilégié des pouvoirs
publics en la matière évidemment la FNS
oui le partenaire particulier de chaque
gouvernement depuis 80 ans qui règne à
lui tout seul sur la quasi totalité des
chambres d'agriculture mais rien ne
s'est passé comme prévu d'abord parce
que la FNSEA a beau être le syndicat
majoritaire elle maîtrise pas les
barrages elle maîtrise pas tous les
coins et notamment le Lot et Garon qui
est une des trois chambres d'agriculture
où la Coordination rurale est arrivée en
tête ensuite parce que et donc du coup
la FNSA a redouté de se voir dépasser
par la base d'un mouvement qu'elle
n'avait pas impulsé he le premier
barrage ce n'est pas elle donc du coup
dès mercredi dernier elle va tenter de
de de canaliser le mouvement en dressant
une plateforme de 122 propositions et
elle dit c'est à prendre ou à laisser ce
qui pas non plus comme dans les
habitudes et et en plus en revenant
parfois sur des éléments qu'elle avait
elle-même signé la FNSEA le fameux gaz
gazol non routier elle avit quand même
signé un accord avec Bercy en septembre
dernier et alors il y a ça qui qui a
changé puis de son côté côé gouvernement
côté Gabriel Atal sa stratégie c'est
contreproductive parce que la
temporisation a créé de l'impatience
voire de la frustration et que la liste
des revendications n'a cessé de grossir
chaque jour un peu plus au fur et à
mesure que différents agriculteurs
rejoignaient le mouvement et quand le
Premier ministre s'est enfin décidé à
parler et ben il a chaussé de bien gros
sabots si j'ose dire pour de bien petits
pas vous vous souvenez devant une botte
de paille il a lâché du concret certes
sur le GNR sur les rapidités
d'indemnisation des épisotypes sur tout
les tous les sujets qu'on a revu dans
dans dans dans le reportage du début
mais il est resté en gros dans l'abset
dans l'abstrait pardon l'absè l's
révélateur et pire de jours plus tard
conscient que ça suffisait pas ben
dimanche il est retourné en André Loir
et là il a dit j'envisage des mesures
supplémentaires et là ce qu'on entendait
c'est Marc F qui dit d'autres mesures
pourra venir donc du coup les
agriculteurs n'ont aucun intérêt à
relâcher la pression avec un enjeu on
l'a dit fort demain discours de
politique générale en début d'après-midi
il peut se rattraper mais ça va être dur
ça va être dur parce que quand vous avez
expliqué pendant une semaine aux
agriculteurs qu'il avaient raison c'est
compliqué de leur dire maintenant faut
rentrer à la maison et on voit bien
géralin faire le grand écart entre on
est compatissant mais attention à ne pas
aller trop loin et puis surtout cet
exercice délicat risque de lui coûter
cher en terme d'argent public beaucoup
plus cher
d'ailleurs Pascal Perino est-ce que le
gouvernement a lâché du lest ou des
mesure ou de l'argent trop tôt
finalement dans ce puisquon on est à
analyser la stratégie c'est facile de
don
oui bien sûr c'est toujours notre rôle
simple observateur euh il fallait
certainement lâcher du l'est pour éviter
que ça dégénère que ces absès de
fixations qui étaient les barrages
dégénèrent avec des comportements de
plus en plus violent hein euh on sait
très bien que les manifestations rurales
peuvent très vite dégénérer en acte de
violence hein souvenons-nous en Bretagne
la mise à sac et l'incendie du Parlement
de Bretagne et CETA on sait que voilà
tout ça peut dégénérer et bien sûr il
s'agit il s'agissait pas de jeter
l'huile sur le feu et donc on a offert
quelques mesures Mathieu vient de le
dire quelques mesures il a pas tout
donné tout de suite tout donné tout de
suite et cetera et on va certainement
dans la déclaration politique générale
même si celle-ci ne peut pas être
entièrement consacrée à la question
agricole c'est une déclaration de
politique générale ou vous voulez
intervenir Nic oui je pense quand même
qu'il a lâché trop tôt le GNR h euh
c'est-à-dire dire euh on on supprime
tout hein ce qui était prévu c'était une
augmentation c un éché progressive
jusqu'à à 2030 euh ça peut-être qu'il
aurait dû le garder euh pour un peu plus
tard mais il fallait bien un peu de
concret et c'est c'est la grande
difficulté de ce mouvement c'est quand
on regarde il y a plein de mesures mais
des mesures euh où quelquefois l'État
français n'a aucun pouvoir enfin y a des
demandes conjoncturell les d'autres qui
sont structurells les structurells on va
en parler un peu plus mais les
conjoncturels c'est quoi par exemple
benah les conjoncturels voilà on est on
est sur euh
sur enfin notamment des des des des
mesures des
réglementations qui sont incohérentes à
appliquer alors ça c'est plutôt
structurel ça c'est structurel oui mais
en fait pour les agriculteurs c'est
maintenant c'est tout de suite voyez ce
que je veux dire la mise en œuvre déjà
cher c'est maintenant la la la gestion
des c'est maintenant les histoires de
cur de fossé qui engendre des des des
inondations ben les agriculteurs le
vivent voyez enfin il y a plein de
choses comme ça
l'é disentous on nous donne ordre et
contreordre c'est c'estadctoon nous
demande quand on regarde dans les
détails c'est vraiment ça c'est-à-dire
qu' ils ne savent pas si on prend la
réglementation par un bout ou par un
autre ça dit le contraire les prairies
je vais vous donner un exemple les
prairies il y a eu un rapport de la Cour
des comptes vous savez qui a qui a dit
il faudrait diminuer les effectifs de
beau vin viande euh pour des raisons
changement climatique impact carbone et
en même temps bah donc si on diminue les
prairies h enfin si on diminue le le le
le le le nombre d'animaux on a moins
besoin de prairies donc les prairies on
les retourne pour faire des grandes des
des cultures h mais ça le problème c'est
que du coup on dégage du carbone en en
en lâchant enfin en retournant des
prairies h donc il faut pas retourner
des prairies et là il y a des sanctions
pour certaines
régions parce que il y a trop de
retournement de prairie voyez on est
dans l'injonction contr contradct c'est
comme la question des ha hein le
gouvernement va faire 50000 km de haie
en France et et la haie elle varie selon
l'usage que vous en faites si vous êtes
près d'une berge c'est le code de
l'environnement qui s'applique si c'est
près d'un coin d'eau potable là c'est le
code de la santé publique si vous êtes
dans un site remarquable c'est le code
de l'environnement mais si prè d'un
patrimoine remarquable c'est le code
patrimonial ça peut être C de l'Urban si
c'est urbanisé ça peut être le code
rural bref voyez qu'ils sont ils sont
perdus mais la question que je poser
c'est il y a pas une mesure que peut
annoncer Gabriel qui produirait un effet
de souffle pour pour arrêter le
mouvement c'est ça c'est ça le problème
non c'est pas évident les j cher je
pense que il y a une cristallisation
tour desjà cher mais votre avis
là-dessus pardon n
interrompe
mes don il l'ont déjà donné là
maintenant on voit pas quand même très
très bien et puis il y a quand même dans
des revendications des choses
où on voit mal quand même le
gouvernement aller jusqu'à accepter il a
accepté déjà beaucoup de choses l'été
dernier tout ça mais là que l'ancesse
soit sous tutelle politique pour décider
de ce qui est cancérigène ou pas c'est
quand même un petit peu aller loin que
l'ofb la police de l'environnement n'it
plus le droit de rentrer sur les
exploitations bon à ce moment-là vous
voulez dire que le gouvernement a déjà
lâché du l'est dans les dans les
semaines ou dans les mois précédents ben
financièrement oui là ce que enfin on on
n pas vu
tout ce qui s'est passé des aides au bio
de plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros des aides comme je dis à la
viticulture tout ça c'est c'est un peu
tous les mois que le gouvernement lâche
du l'est donc là il peut aller encore
plus loin g de l'eau aussi la gestion de
l'eau aussi oui alors puisqu'on est sur
les marges de manœuvre je reste avec
vous jeanchist bureau parce que il y a
quand même la question de la de la
grande distribution et de l'application
de la loi
égalim là j'ai j'ai lu qu'il y avait des
des enquêtes diligentées par la DGCCRF
la répression des des fautes ça vis qui
les distributeurs surtout les
distributeurs ouais donc des grands
groupes mais c'est quoi les géants de la
grande distribution les hypermarchés
pour ne pas les nommer les centrale
d'achat de March c'est c'est quand même
eu he qui on qui quoi qui ont tout fait
pour enfin pour certaines ont contourn
la loi Galim c'est ça alors la loi Galim
moi j'ai jamais complètement comprise
pour rien vous cacher mais c'est censé
garantir un revenu donc basé sur les
coûts de production mais si vous voulez
sur certains produits sur le blé c'est
pas c'est pas le coût de production qui
fait le prix c'est à combien l'achètent
les Égyptiens donc il y a quand même des
fondamentaux un peu un peu boiteux dans
cette loi et c'est vrai que les
centrales d'achat bon déjà on leur
demande de combattre l'inflation donc
ils ont pression sur les prix et puis
eux ils savent jouer sur les contours de
la loi pour que l'esprit de la loi ne
soit plus appqué mais effectivement par
que Pascal Perin en période d'inflation
justement peut-être que ça arrangait un
peu le gouvernement que là aussi on
parle d'injonction contradictoire que la
loigalim soit on va
dire plus ou moins appliqué quoi bien
sûr parce app
stricte si tent quand je vous écoute que
ce soit possible d'appliquer strictement
un texte un peu confus voilà ça ça
permettait de lutter contre l'inflation
si on a pu ce moyen de lutte contre
l'inflation la grande distribution c'est
même quelque chose d'essentiel hein dans
la lutte contre l'inflation donc là on
se prive d'un instrument et on donc on
va satisfaire une
clientèle et minoritaire pour mettre
peut-être accentuer la grogne qui qui
existe chez les Français n'oublions pas
qu'en ce moment la hausse des prix et
l'inflation est le premier enjeu aux
yeux des Français quel que soit leur âge
quel que soit le milieu social et cetera
donc il faut jouer avec ces différents
paramètres c'est la contradiction Nicole
Ouvrard c'est que les Français
soutiennent le mouvement mais ils sont
pas forcément prêts à payer plus cher
des produits agricoles soit bio soit
produit en France effectivement Bruno Le
Maire il y a pas si longtemps expliquait
à quel point il fallait effectivement
que la grande distribution joue le jeu
pour réduire enfin diminuer les prix
donc euh effectivement c'est pas si
simple la loi égalim mais s'applique
pour les produits qui sont
commercialisés en France produits en
France pour être commercialisés en
France donc voilà les produits laitiers
euh c'est typiquement le le le le
l'exemple et d'ailleurs la loi égalime a
eu un effet positif les premières années
aujourd'hui effectivement la grande
distribution a trouvé des moyens de la
contourner soit en négociant en ne
respectant pas soit en en installant des
centrales d'achat à l'extérieur de la
France qui permettent en fait d'échapper
à cette règle donc là aussi il y a il y
a des solutions mais vraiment enfin il
faut aussi prendre en compte le fait
qu'il y aura peut-être des sanctions
pour des industries agroalimentaires
aussi au-delà de la grande distribution
ouis je vous propose d'entendre le
ministre de l'Agriculture tout de suite
Marc F on va on a commencé à l'évoquer
mais on va détailler un petit peu il n'a
en ce moment qu'un mot à la bouche c'est
le mot
simplification on a besoin de travailler
sur la simplification on a besoin pardon
de l'expression d'ouvrir le moteur de
regarder ce qui est incohérent dans les
simplifi dans les dans les
réglementations qui sont en cours ce qui
produit de la paperacee ou de la
papeacerie qui est inutile ce qui
produit de la suradministration et ce
qui produit chez les agriculteurs le
sentiment que finalement on n'est pas à
l'écoute d'une volonté de simplification
générale et donc on a besoin de créer
les conditions de la confiance et pour
créer les condition condition de la
confiance il faut qu'on regarde
réglementation par réglementation et
j'ai poursuivi ce matin le travail qui a
été souhaité par le Premier ministre par
le Président de la République de
regarder qui sur la PAC qui sur la
réglementation qu'est-ce qui pouvait
être des freins qu'est-ce qui posait
problème et qu'est-ce qui au fond
donnait le sentiment aux agriculteurs
qui passaient plus de temps sur ces
sujets là que sur le sujet de la
production jean-christop bureau les les
les hricupteurs sont pas les seuls à
être confrontés à la à la complexité
administrative en France est-ce qu'ils
sont encore plus mal lotis que d'autres
après vous
oui parce qu'il y a
vraiment là maintenant on a délégué
Bruxelles ça devient difficile
d'attaquer vraiment Bruxelles bon là les
4 % de jcher c'est bien bruxellois mais
le reste tout a été délégué à la France
depuis le 1er janvier 2023 la pâac on
peut enlever le C au bout he c'est
collection de politique national qui
s'appelle les plans stratégiques
nationaux on a redonné la main au au
étatè complètementel de la France il
fait quand même 1200 pages et ça ça
s'ajoute au code rural au code de
l'environnement au code de tout ça qui
en font pas mal d'articles quand même
quoi du coup c'est quand même pas très
très simple pour eux donc c'est pas
simple pour eux mais est-ce que c'est
simple pour le ministre de tenir la
promesse de simplification
et comme c'est difficile pour le
ministre la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur je ne souhaite aucun
agriculteur être dans l'évaluation du ha
conseil de l'enseignement la recherche
où je suis actuellement si vous voulez
c'est un enfer bureaucratique et on
parle de simplification quoi moi ça fait
10 jours que je suis dedans j'ai
toujours pas compris ce que je doais
faire mais les agriculteurs c'est à peu
près pareil quoiou c'est français le
problème est plus français qu'agricole
je pense oui parce que simplification
administrative ça suppose aussi des
choix politiques Nicole ouvra ah bah oui
on revient aux injonctions
contradictoires dont on parlait tout à
l'heure il faut bien voir que quelqu
fois la norme et la surtransposition
elle a du bon surtransposition on
rappelle ce que c'est c'est les normes
européennes on fait mieux ou plus ça on
va plus loin en fait que que la norme
européenne euh la loi égalime est une
sur surtransposition excusez-moi puisque
effectivement on met des règles pour
faire en sorte de prendre en compte le
le coût de production de la matière
première agricole dans le coût global de
l'alimentation ça c'est de la
surtransposition positive si on peut
dire donc quelquefois ça va dans le sens
des agriculteurs là c'est le cas par
contre Ben par exemple toutes les
interdictions de molécules euh
supplémentaires par rapport à au au
nombre de molécules autorisé au niveau
européen quand quand en France on en
supprime davantage et là il y a encore
une série de de 70 nouvelles molécules
qui vont être interdites là on est dans
la
surtransposition qui est problématique
pour les agriculteurs et qui est source
en fait de de distorsion de concurrence
si on peut dire alors on cherche dans ce
zbat à évaluer a évoqué des sorties de
crise potentiell on a vu quelle pouvait
être la stratégie du gouvernement on va
maintenant se concentrer plus côté
syndicale parce que là aussi c'est assez
intéressant de voir quel est le la la la
la marge de manœuvre et et les
possibilités les différents syndicats
d'agir sur ce mouvement je propose à
Steve Jourdain de nous rejoindre on va
bonsoir Steve on va voilà faire une
espèce de de de tableau de l'état des
syndicats agricoles en France on
commence évidemment par le premier
d'entre eux FNS la très puissante FNSEA
la Fédération nationale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles elle a été
fondée après la guerre en 1946 c'est un
syndicat euh historiquement marqué à
droite en droite plutôt Gauliste en 2022
sa présidente d'allor Christian Lambert
avait appelé à voter contre Marine Le
Pen elle se prononçait pour une Europe
plus forte face aux tentations
populistes fin de citation en matière de
représentativité la FNSEA est de très
très loin le plus alors ça c'est
Christian Lambert he c'est voilà F de
très très loin le plus important syndic
agricole elle remporte régulièrement les
élections des chambres d'agriculture en
2019 dernier scrutin en date le syndicat
avait recueilli plus de 55 % des
suffrages c'est une très grosse machine
elle revendique plus de 210000 adhérents
pas étonnant que dans le contexte actuel
l'exécutif tente un peu de de choyer ces
dirigeants qui était le premier syndicat
reçu à matigon depuis le début de la
crise F la FNSEA reçu de nouveau en
cette fin d'après-midi de de lundi alors
il y a d'autres syndicats d'agriculteurs
évidemment certains très mobilisés dans
le mouvement actuel oui syndicat des
jeunes agriculteurs qui a annoncé le
siège de Paris à partir de ce lundi créé
en
1957 c'est un syndicat qui est dédié au
moins de 38 ans il se dit apolitique et
indépendant et revendique 50000
adhérents l'une de ses raisons d'être et
dit-il d'assurer le renouvellement des
générations en agriculture c'est un
allié de la FNSEA organisation avec
laquelle les JA ont fait liste commune
aux élections de 2019 FNSEA et jeunes
agriculteurs font pas forcément
l'unanimité au au au sein de la
profession non principal le concurrent
de la FNSA la Coordination Rurale c'est
elle he vous vous en souvenez qui a jeté
du lisier sur la préfecture d'agin la
semaine dernière elle a des méthodes
disons beaucoup plus musclées que les
autres elle est coutumière des actions
coup de point c'est le 2è syndicat
agricole avec 15000 adhérant il a été
fondé en 1991 à l'époque ses fondateurs
reprochai à la FNSEA d'être complice de
du pouvoir qu'ils accusent de céder aux
normes adoptées par l'Union européenne
la gauche dit de la Coordination Rurale
qu'elle est un syndicat extrême droite
une organisation clairement
anti-écologiste mais elle récuse ses
allégations elle revendique le
rétablissement de la préférence
communautaire et la défense des fermes
familiales et puis il y a aussi un autre
syndicat qu'on entend un peu moins dans
ce mouvement oui un syndicat classé à
gauche la Confédération paysane son
soutien à la mobilisation des
agriculteurs est un peu plus discrète
que les autres elle a été créée en 1987
et porte un discours différent de celui
de la FNSEA elle n'exige pas la
réduction des normes environnementales
et revendique un discours alterre mon
mondialiste et
agro-écologiste avec plus de 19 % des
voix aux élections de 2019 c'est le 3e
syndicat de France à noté Thomas que ce
classement sera probablement ou
peut-être disons remis en jeu l'année
prochaine en 2025 auront lieu les
élections professionnelles d'où
l'importance de la mobilisation actuelle
pour tous ces syndicats qui veulent se
montrer à côté de leurs potentiels
électeurs évidemment il y a aussi cet
enjeu merci beaucoup Steve Nicole
ouvrage je reviens vers vous parce que
il y a il y a la question de la
représentativité syndicale de
éventuellement dépassé par leur base on
l'a évoqué rapidement dans dans dans ce
débat la FNSEA c'est le plus puissant
mais est-ce qu'il a un peu perdu le
contact avec la base ou pas bah ils ont
un un superbe
réseau très ancré dans chaque
département dans chaque commune canton
donc il y a un réseau très structuré
donc et avec des filières aussi il est
structuré sur le territoire et il est
structuré par filière lait viande et
cetera et cetera donc donc le réseau
mais quand même un peu dépassé par la
base dans ce mouvement ben en fait dans
la mesure où il se veut on va dire
raisonnable dans sa politique il va
effectivement négocier des des choses
avec le
gouvernement qui sont peut-être
quelquefois en décalage avec ce que
vivent les agriculteurs ce que disait
Mathieu tout à l'heure c'estàd que là
ils ont dans dans la liste des
revendication ils sont ils sont revenus
en arrière quoi par rapport à bah oui
tout à fait et je pense que euh la la
FNSEA aujourd'hui est dans cette
approche de prise en compte de
l'agroécologie de prise en compte de la
transition agricole et et si Arnaud
Rousseau a négocié le fait qu' il
pouvait y avoir une augmentation
progressive de du GNR c'est aussi dans
cette approche disant il faut
effectivement composer avec la société
ce qui n'est pas forcément compris hy
Pascal Perino ça complique la tâche du
gouvernement ça d'avoir un mouvement qui
est O où le principal interlocuteur est
tient pas forcément sa base oui ça
arrive assez souvent mais il faut noter
pour la FNSA tout même une chose si vous
voulez dans quand vous prenez un peu de
champ vous regardez les syndicats les
syndicats en France ont un gros problème
de représentativité vous savez on dit
que par exemple c'est à peu près 8 % des
salariés en France là on est dans un
autre univers des salariés qui sont
syndqués là FF c'est pas le cas si vous
voulez ils ont au travers de leur réseau
une véritable implantation ça reste le
syndicat le plus représentatif j'allais
dire statistiquement de la base qu'il
prétend représenter hein donc quand on
fait top là avec la
FNSEA on va voir ce qui se passe ce soir
dans les jours qui viennent mais ça a
peut-être un peu endormi le gouvernement
ou Marc fen dans les dans les mois qui
ont
précédé comme ça a été noté tout à
l'heure il faut bien voir que le conflit
part d'une zone qui était pas une zone
FNSE hein ça part d'une zone
coordination Coordination rurale et
ensuite la FNSEA prend le train en
marche encadre anime et j'allais dire
pour l'instant tiens ses troupes hein
donc si vous voulez il n'y aura aucune
solution quelle qu'elle soit euh en
dehor à la périphérie de la FNSEA voilà
il faut discuter discuter et encore
discuter pour sortir de cette crise il
faut passer par la FNS que les choses
soient so
je oui allez-y ce sont les j quand même
sont les J et les voilà les jeunes
agriculteurs et et la FRSEA qui ont
démarré ce mouvement à carbone enfin
c'était quand même mais effectivement ça
a été vite récupéré et
amplifié et avec la Coordination Rurale
effectivement à agin petit focus sur la
Coordination Rurale justement Steve
jouran nous disait dans dans dans son
dans sa chronique que euh elle était
étiquetée par certains comme d'extrême
droite votre avis là-dessus Christophe
Bur est-ce qu'elle roule pour Marine Le
Pen je vais simplifier la question eux
s'en défendent oui voilà mais vous
connaissez bien le vous connaissez bien
le secteur vous vous devez vous devez
avoir des élments pour nous dire si
c'est vrai ou pas trs très
anti-européens ou euh très antieuropéen
alors même que ils ont été quand même
beaucoup créés par des des grandes des
des exploitants de grandes cultures
assez
large qui reçoivent quand même
énormément d'argent européen c'est pas
justement les petits éleveurs de 20
hectares d'Occitanie qui qui bénéficient
de cet argent européen donc c'est assez
paradoxal et ce qui a été rappelé c'est
que Madame Lambert dans l'élection de
2017 avait quand même l'idée que le
frxit enfin c'était quand même se tirer
une balle dans le pied avec tout ce qui
nous arrivait de Bruxelles ça n'a pas
empêché une partie du monde agricole de
quand même glisser vers le rassemblement
national d'où un certain nombre de
cadeaux qui ont été faits depuis 7 ans
maintenant beaucoup par Julien de
Normandie pour le précédent ministre de
l'Agriculture voilà avec la FNSEA pour
essayer de de ramener ce monde là dans
enfin dans dans une
zone plus plus centriste on va dire
Pascal Perino ça va se jouer à Bruxelles
alors là c'est plus Gabriel Atal qui va
être à la manœuvre c'est c'est Emmanuel
Macron on va on va voir comment
fonctionne le duo aussi il y a aussi ce
test là bien sûr bien sûr il y a on le
voit bien comme toujours la le le duo
président de la République euh Premier
ministre se joue dans ces grandes crises
et Gabriel Atal a aussi le besoin
d'exister parce qu'il a été présenté
comme le clone la créature d'Emmanuel
Macron et la créature une fois qu'elle
est à Matignon il a besoin d'exister
souvenons-nous du duo Fabius mitteran
hein peu à peu Fabius a eu le besoin
d'exister lui c'est lui moi c'est moi
hein et bien je crois que dans cette
crise même s'il y a peut-être un aspect
moins aguéri moins frondeur peut-être
chez chez Gabriel Atal se joue aussi
cela il va gagner il va y gagner en poid
politique peut y gagner en poid il peut
il peut se brûler les ailes il peut y
gagner en poids hein et ça sera
important pour pour Gabriel Atal parce
qu'il faut qu'il sorte absolument d'une
carrière qui jusqu'à maintenant est une
carrière où c'était le premier de la
classe en terme d'opinion hein là on
joue dans une autre catégorie ou est-ce
que c'est cour des grands ouais est-ce
que Nicole Ouvrard c'est le c'est aussi
puisque on l'a dit c'est un mouvement
européen il y a il y a aussi pression
sur ce fameux pacte vert le Green Deal
européen là si on cherche un point
commun au aux différents syndicat
agricole dans ces pays d'Europe aux
revendications disparates dont vous nous
avez parlé c'est quoi c'est c'est
s'opposer à ce Green Deal ah ouais je
pense qu'il y a ça et puis et puis euh
ce r bol desnmes oui je pense oui oui
tout à fait c'est c'est je pense que
c'est vraiment ça qui qui est en commun
alors avec des démarrages effectivement
différents hein au Pays-Bas ce sont les
nitrates en même temps ils sont allés
très loin dans l'intensification donc
effectivement aujourd'hui là on leur
demande ben de de de réduire la
production et de réduire le nombre
d'élevages euh donc chaque pays a ses
ass ses différences mais la le point
commun c'est en fait il faut bien voir
qu'on a eu une séquence sur la fin de
l'année 2023 euh où euh tous les textes
européens t les règlements concernés par
le Green Deal ont été ont été votés ou
pas d'ailleurs parfois avec difficulté
avec difficulté ou pas du tout
effectivement mais en tout cas il y a eu
une séquence un peu longue et un peu
lourde avec tous les jours nous au
niveau d'Agra tous les jours on donnait
l'état d'avancement de ces débats ces
discussions c cintes ça devient de plus
en plus concret ou potentiellement
concret pour les agriculteurs français
c'est ça c'est ça et avec des des épé
d'amocles qui qui qui risque de tomber
quoi jeanc bureau à quel point c'est un
changement de modèle ce ce pacte vert
s'il était appliqué mais alors déjà il y
a absolument rien d'appliqué qui touche
l'agriculture c'est pour ça on est
contre les normes du pactur mais elle
n'existe pas n'existe pas pour l'instant
et je pense qu' existeront jamais en
tout cas pas
grand-chose moi je pense que le problème
le fait que ce soit européen vous avez
tout à fait raison c'est qu'on a quand
même donner énormément d'argent et on
donne énormément d'argent aux
agriculteurs et là petit à petit on leur
dit mais cet argent vous l'avez mais il
faut le conditionner à de plus en plus
de choses et des choses extrêmement
bureaucratiques inapplicables l'argement
et ça si vous voulez c'est une politique
qui ne peut pas marcher parce que il est
assez significatif que ce qu'on appelait
le single farm payment au niveau
européen nous on les traduit par droit à
paiement unique en France ce qui veut
dire que les agriculteurs ont le droit à
cet argent c'est vraiment très très
enfin c'est très établi ça et maintenant
pour laavir il faudrait faire de la
jachè il faudrait ne pas mettre de ncï
enfin plein de choses comme ça ça ne
peut pas marcher on va avoir un
lobbyisme qui va demander des exemptions
et les obtenir et ils ont à peu près
tout obtenu quand même faut dire ce
qu'il y est depuis depuis 4 ou 5 ans et
du coup le Green Deal est inapplicable
ce qu'il faudrait c'est repartir d'une
page blanche ce qui est politiquement
absolument impossible donc ça veut dire
que le le le virage écologiste de
l'agriculture européenne n'aura pas lieu
ce que vous nous dites il était assez
bien parti je aurais pas dit ça il y a
18 mois on avait vraiment une impulsion
vous aviez le programme de gouvernement
de la coalition allemande qui était très
très pro Green Deal on va arrêter les
aid PAC on va faire comme les Anglais
des aides à l'environnement vous aviez
le le gouvernement hollandais qui était
on arrête cette agriculture industrielle
très polluante parce que les coûts du
nitrate c'est énorme c'est énorme enfin
de l'azote en général et on on passe une
agriculture plus plus agroécologique on
va dire donc il y avait un véritable
mouvement et puis même au niveau du
Parlement européen c'était pas mal vu le
Green Deal parce qu'il y avait le plan
de relance derrière et là ça a basculé
au printemps 2023 en particulier à cause
des élections Pays-Bas qui ont amené cet
obscure partie à des niveaux absolument
gigantesqu dans les sondages élection
sénatoriales plus plus que les sondages
élections sénatoriales 15 sièg et et ça
ça ça a totalement paniqué le PPE le
parti européen demande Fred Weber qui
d'un seul coup est passé du côté
anti-green deal et qui a été suivi par
la plupart des États-membres h merci
beaucoup merci à à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat et
à bientôt sur Public Sénat